it's tough it's a real Tuffy
bring on the burgers bring on the
lipitor what to Seth Rogen Adam Richman
and Tiffani Thiessen all have in common
if they pull no punches when it comes to
rating Ellie's best burgers for LA food
& Wine's burger throwdown I gathered 25
of the city's top burger spots and
narrowed it down to three contestants
for our all-star panel of judges to
taste who deserves the crown a pop-up
smash burger as on rebending filipino
burger or a pared down classic friends
yes welcome we have plenty of stuff to
talk about what defines the classic LA
burger
I think classic le burger to me are like
pretty simple with like one defining
feature Apple fan is like a very simple
burger but they have that sauce Nick I
saw love that add like in-and-out burger
again it's like a British mr. burger but
they have it at its core it's like a
pretty simple like thin patty you know
not giant thing didn't you tell me that
Seth was the one who said that thick
patties are for [ __ ] yeah I don't
like big patty burgers lump in paradise
in patties fatties are for [ __ ]
like I don't think of LA like in terms
of like a brioche bun with like romaine
lettuce or something on it yeah I think
about something that sort of soft and
pliable but something we live in
California the weather is amazing you're
always barbecuing and grilling outside
all I ask is that you know we keep a
couple of criteria in mind one is you
know technical is it like sear as a bun
gray two are the ratios right and three
what sets them apart from everybody else
what's their x-factor most of things I
used to say about boyfriend's rank on
the burger
bring on the lipitor I'm mark trip and
this is trip burgers I run a smash
burger pop-up here in Los Angeles I got
into the hamburger world after seeing
George Motz as a documentary hamburger
America I worked in advertising for 35
years recently got out of advertising
and decided to go full-bore with the the
pop up with la you can kind of literally
roll up on a sidewalk with your taco
cart griddle and start a business the
blend from my recipe is chuck top
sirloin bacon so I start with a ball
just flew over 2 ounces smash it with my
smash Allah get it nice and thin and I
wait till there's a nice lacy edge flip
it over and put a piece of American
cheese on it toast that Martin's potato
bun and then put them all together what
sets my blend apart from just about
everybody else's burgers that I've tried
is the bacon
it gives it a smokiness a little
richness to it that that other regular
burgers don't have the first category is
smash burger March trip he doesn't have
a restaurant he doesn't have a food
truck it's a car town drill oh yeah it's
a griddle that he popular ideas burgers
and he makes this word [ __ ] yeah
this burger actually has ground bacon in
it whoa so much coach yeah it looks like
a Shake Shack burger first blush let's
hit it let's say that's [ __ ] good
definitely taste the bacon in that you
can definitely taste the bacon mmm and
not kind of caramelized crunchy sort of
sear on them that's the best part
having crispy bacon in the morning some
condiments
listen up maybe sometimes we need a
little bit of cotton hell yes
blend on the burger burger mustard
pickle I just try to emulate the
cheeseburger picnic
oh you've been doing this for like five
months really yeah every hype b-style
foodie has like a pop about this burgers
put those off-white little red tags yeah
exactly this is a virtual hablo
off-white burger that's like burger in
quotes got take it up a notch and we'll
go with like the burger with pedigrees
like trendy burger yeah yeah we're born
with the record with the next category
the iconic got it or at the airport
everybody yeah I'm Chad Valencia I'm the
chef/owner of a Filipino American
restaurant in LA called lhasa so the
burger is inspired by a Filipino dish
called bistec a stewed or braised dish
of beef and onions
so we seasoned the griddle we get the
patty on we get a nice carmelization on
the bottom onions that are stewed and
seasoned with soy yo soy sauce and
Muncie Edam cheese after the buns get
toasted we put a little bit of cumin CA
Oly on it just to bring some of that
brightness up the kind of different
thing is we dip it in jus like you would
a french dip you know we grew up eating
burgers but you grew up also eating
Filipino food we're proud of it
we're proud of it category number two
iconic class okay the burger from off
the beaten path as something super
unique this is a Filipino inspired
burger and this is the the beef beef
shoe that classically in the in the
Filipino dish would be boiled it's a
Bijou
[Applause]
is exciting hmm Filipino if it's not
song yeah yeah exactly
it's very authentically Filipino and
heavily seasoned all biasness aside me
being Filipino and me like yeah loving
Filipino food like this actually nails
the flavor
we need a burger with some to stop doing
this joke they just want Food and Wine
magazine's best restaurant of the year
yes so they heard yeah they have a
pedigree so this stuff fine-dining
burger burger only available on the
weekends it's it has pedigree but on
that note have you ever been to a
Hollywood party where there's like an
extravagant foodie experience like you
walk in and like Gordon Ramsay's in the
backyard cooking a burger no please tell
me I go like let me live in your life
for like two seconds I'm good the things
we're yeah like Wolfgang Puck is like
they're like Oh handing out pizzas and
[ __ ] like that
yeah I'm a basic-cable not at the
Weather Channel you get my entire oeuvre
my name is Foster Ramos and I'm the head
chef of Everson Roy's bar in downtown LA
we do the single burger here very simple
we start off with a four ounce patty so
our ground beef chuck mixes and special
beef blend that we get from Huntington
meats we place a brioche bun on the
grill after the bun is toasted lightly
we're spread it with our house-made
dejeuner sauce after the patty forms a
nice crust on one side we flip one piece
of Telemark cheddar on it lightly melt
it bun goes on and that's it two Spears
of pickles and that's all we need
simple classic la third category classic
yep meats cheese bun is the brioche bun
is made by the same bakers that make in
and out whoa
do you put the pickles on it I always do
for me if it's on the side I'm taking it
like a shot appellate clam well it is
vinegar medium rare
I like the Dijonnaise almost makes it
like garlic bread sauce ok key
I almost wish this with like a grilled
potato but instead the ratio sorry I
feel like there's a little much there's
a little too much look at the top button
what was this good shape and he said
that like everything should almost be
that the same size yeah man what you
script it down it is yeah I've had this
one physically at the restaurant a
couple times yeah
and this one tonight stay something a
little different and I know sometimes
when you're having to cook for a mass
amount of people their ratios can be a
little off I feel like it's a lot
heavier in the garlic yeah right now
before we make the decision of the best
of these three I have to know right down
the line [ __ ] marry kill
in and out Shake Shack Five Guys what's
your order I've never had a Five Guys
burger
whoa I have it smells funny
smells like Sisler's cheese bread it was
grotesque
well since ok you guys both bowed out it
so that's we have to kill just yeah that
is the answer anyway so if it's the
shack Meister like I be cool just having
that one like every day forever yeah and
so now I'm gonna do the Shack Meister
Mary and then I'd [ __ ] the double-double
animal style okay which I usually do at
least once Mary
[Music]
I'm a lady I don't talk like that back
to the task ahead all right
that's gonna be hard they're very
different well they're not very
different you think there's a clear
winner well I mean for me I'm torn
between two me to the this one and the
first wheelchair
that's my team just cuz it was the most
interesting and they're going different
what the [ __ ] going on it's your bet
to save warriors come out here
texturally structurally and how
interesting it was I'm gonna go with the
iconoclast the Filipino burger okay the
shoe I think I'm gonna go with the trip
trip I am because even though I know I
said I wanted condiments on I love the
flavor of that burger it's tough it's a
real Tuffy I'll go I would go with the
first one there you have it folks strip
burger y'all did it
they put bacon in there they put baby in
there bacon in anything let us keep the
line if we ever show ya guys we get it
cellphone number
[Music]
what's up everybody it's having Kyle out
of the burger show make sure you turn on
your notifications smash that like
button smash that subscribe button and
thank you for watching